when you're doing that kind of back and
forth on the topic like the economy
which you have to me or have some naive
but it seems both incredible and
incredibly complex the economy the
trading the transactions that these
transactions between two individuals
somehow add up to this giant mechanism
you've put out a 30 minute video you
have a lot of incredible videos online
that people should definitely watch on
YouTube but you've put out this 30
minute video titled how the economic
machine works that is probably one of
the best if not the best video I've seen
on the Internet in terms of educational
videos so people should definitely watch
it especially because it's not that the
individual components of the video are
somehow revolutionary but the simplicity
and the clarity of the different
components just makes you there's a few
light bulb moments there about what how
the economy works as a machine so as you
described there's three main forces that
drive the economy productivity growth
short term debt cycle long term debt
cycle the the former productivity growth
is how valuable things how much value
people create valuable things people
create the latter is people borrowing
from the their future selves to
hopefully create those valuable things
faster so this is an incredible system
to me
maybe we can linger on in a little bit
but you've also said well most people
think about as money is actually credit
total amount of credit in the u.s. is 50
trillion dollars total amount of money
is three trillion dollars that's just
crazy to me
maybe maybe I'm silly maybe you can
educate me but that seems crazy
it gives me just pause that the human
civilization has been able to create a
system that has so much credit so that's
a long way to ask do you think credit is
good or bad for society that system of
that's so fundamentally based on credit
I think credit is great even though
people
often overdo it the credit is that
somebody has earned money yeah and you
know and what happens is they lend it to
somebody else who's got better ideas and
they cut a deal and then that person
with the better ideas is gonna pay it
back and if it works well it helps
resource allocations go well providing
people look like the entrepreneurs and
all of those they need capital
they don't have capital themselves and
so somebody's gonna give them capital
and they'll give them credit and along
those lines then what happens is it's
not managed well in a variety of ways so
I did a another book on principles
principles of big debt crisis that go
into that and it's free by the way I met
put it free online on as a PDF so if you
go online and you look principles for
big debt crisis is under my name you can
download it in a PDF where you can buy a
print book of it and it goes through
that particular process and so you
always have it over done in all ways the
same way everything by the way almost
everything happens over and over again
for the same reasons okay so these debt
crisis has all happen over and over
again for the same reasons they get it
over done in the book it explains how
you identify whether it's overdone or
not they get it overdone and then you go
through the process of making the
adjustments according that and then and
it explains how they can use the levers
and so on if you didn't have credit then
you would be sort of everybody sort of
be stuck so credit is a good thing but
it can easily be overdone so now we get
into the quote what is money what is
credit okay you get into money and
credit so if you're holding credit and
you think that's worthwhile keep in mind
that the central bank let's say it can
print the money what is that problem
they you have an IOU and the IOU says
you're going to get a certain number of
dollars let's say or yen or euros and
that is what the IOU is and so the
question is will you get that money and
what
what will it be worth and then also you
have a government which is a participant
in that process because they want they
are on the hook they old money and then
will they print the money to make it
easy for everybody to pay so you have to
pay attention to those two I would
suggest like you you recommend to other
people just take that 30 minutes and it
in it and it comes across pretty clearly
but the my conclusion is that of course
you want it and even if you understand
it and the cycles well you can benefit
from those cycles rather than to be hurt
by those cycles because I don't know the
way the cycle works if somebody gets
over indebted they have to sell an asset
okay then I don't know me that's when
assets become cheaper how do you acquire
the asset it's a whole process
you